[Music]
it's incredible to be here with all the
nominees in the best director category
from the start of the film to the end of
the film it's like flying on the outside
of the airplane for me i love the way
you can
talk to someone and make them feel free
watch the blood like come up into their
face and what does it take to have that
relationship with someone i think what
really spoke to me about it it's super
electric i thought it was so funny and
then really stressful and i would say
my domain is stressful comedy i'm very
interested in
exploring and exposing the male gaze in
different ways i think that's where the
first suit came i was adamant from the
beginning with my producers like that we
aren't using doubles this is not a sport
you can pick up in an afternoon or even
a week it's like someone has to do it i
have to be able to do it and i need that
kind of like neurotic drive i felt this
was the first time
that i ever
really got comfortable with hearing a
better idea than my own we do this thing
where strangers go into dark room and
watch another person's dream and it's
cool like it's just like a thing we do i
think sometimes when there's a lot of
death around
it can make people double down on being
alive
and i think that is what happened on our
set